bueno significaría puntualmente que
encuentra el sistema político encuentra
más equilibrio de poder que la oposición
fundamentalmente
juntos por el cambio la fuerza política
de la cual es el ex presidente mauricio
macri pasaría a ser la primera minoría
en el congreso y también
digamos reduciría el poder que tiene
actualmente la vicepresidenta cristina
fernández de kirchner en el senado con
la capacidad de convocar y hacer quórum
propio así que lo que se lograría
fundamentalmente es mayor equilibrio y
por supuesto control en las iniciativas
legislativas
bueno cuáles fueron los factores que
llevaron al gobierno de alberto
fernández a esta situación tan precaria
si los resultados le resultan
desfavorables que podemos esperar de la
actual coalición gubernamental con la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández que ya
mostró fracturas en los meses
posteriores a las paso
sí exactamente bueno los factores son
múltiples en parte por supuesto la
eficiente
conducción o administración de todo el
proceso de la pandemia de la crisis
sanitaria en segundo lugar los problemas
referidos a la situación económica la
inflación como bien dijiste eso es un
problema que sigue creciendo y no el
gobierno no ha mantenido un plan
antiinflacionario y por supuesto también
tiene que ver la el problema del empleo
es decir hay una agenda económica social
que incluye también la gestión de la
crisis sanitaria que en conjunto ha
creado muchísimo malestar en la sociedad
argentina y por supuesto también tiene
que ver en la dificultad que ha mostrado
el presidente de poder
dirigir digamos tomar decisiones de
manera autónoma del vicepresidente a la
perspectiva de la sociedad argentina es
que hay un poder compartido y que no se
ponen de acuerdo entre la presidenta y
el presidente de la vicepresidenta en
qué dirección qué rumbo quiere tomar el
gobierno para resolver algunas
cuestiones fundamentales por ejemplo el
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional
analistas aseguran que estas elecciones
podrían llevar a una estado a una
inestabilidad política aún mayor a la
que ya se vive y que se une a lo que ya
estábamos mencionando la inflación el
desempleo y la deuda por ejemplo desde
su perspectiva cuál es la solución a
este panorama y algún resultado
específico que podría ayudar a que el
país tenga una mayor estabilidad
bueno es cierto que después de los
resultados de las primarias que fue de
alguna manera fue una sorpresa un golpe
electoral para el presidente fernández
la semana siguiente fueron bastante
inestables con renuncias de parte del
gabinete que finalmente no aceptó una
carta de la vicepresidenta que tomaba
distancia del presidente fernández es
decir después de las primarias hubo ya
un fuerte cimbronazo político
de reacción al resultado adverso que
tuvo el gobierno lo que se espera de
aquí en más es que el gobierno tenga que
si efectivamente se confirman los
resultados que ya tuvo en las primarias
y los resultados de hoy son en la misma
dirección se espera que el gobierno
transita en los dos años los dos
próximos años que terminan su mandato
con con mucha inestabilidad si no logra
y si no logra precisamente resolver los
conflictos que tiene hacia de la propia
coalición de gobierno que podría hacerse
podría ser en primer lugar que el propio
espacio del presidente junto con la
vicepresidenta de las fuerzas políticas
que integran su coalición lleguen a un
acuerdo que sea explícito sobre algunos
de los lineamientos más importantes que
tiene por delante el gobierno y luego a
partir de ahí podría convocarse a un
acuerdo más amplio que involucre al
resto de las fuerzas políticas pero lo
que dice ahora la oposición es que
mientras el propio espacio de gobierno
es decir el presidente la vicepresidenta
y los otros dirigentes políticos de su
coalición no logren ponerse de acuerdo
ellos en primer lugar es difícil que
puedan establecer un acuerdo con el
resto de las fuerzas políticas sí señora
gent de rosas a usted muchísimas gracias
personal y sí sí por compartirlo con
nosotros en france 24